- [Announcer] This program
is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
noncommercial use only.
(electronic synthesizer music)
- So first an update from yesterday.
I paraphrased a quote
that science marches on,
funeral by funeral.
Here's the exact quote as
emailed to me this afternoon.
It comes from Max Plank.
"A new scientific truth does not triumph
"by convincing its opponents
and making them see the light,
"but rather because its
opponents eventually die,
"and a new generation grows
up that is familiar with it."
And paraphrasing, "Truth never triumphs,
"its opponents just die
out," or the version I gave.
Thanks to Paul Sas for sending me that.
Much of what I'm gonna talk about today
comes from my book, "Nudge,"
which we'll get to in a little while
that was written with Cass Sunstein.
Cass and I tried to make
the distinction between
the people that economists
model and the rest of us,
and to shorten it, we call
the agents of economic models,
econs, and real people, humans.
Now, how do they differ?
Well economists really
assume that economists
are as smart as they are
or really as smart as they think they are.
And the norm in economics has become
that suppose some old guy
like me writes down some model
of rational behavior and then,
a younger guy, like Matthew, comes along,
but a rational version of
Matthew in every sense,
and thinks of way in which
the agents in my model
could be smarter.
Then the norm has become
that his model is better than my model.
And as a result, the
agents in economic models
have gotten smarter and
smarter over the last 60 years,
and we haven't.
So as a result, there's
been this growing divide
that probably peaked in the 1980s
of when hyper-rational models
were very much in fashion,
and so the agents are
really, really smart,
and we're just sort of plodding along.
Now thanks to neuro-economics,
we've been able to
establish the actual truth.
(audience laughing)
So, there you go.
That's a visual image
of bounded rationality.
I was trying to get this.
That's the last thing I'm going to say
about neuro-economics.
The second way in which economists differ,
econs differ from humans is,
humans have self-control problems.
Homer, when told by a gun shop owner
that there's a five-day waiting period
for a gun he wants to
buy to kill somebody,
says, "Five days?
"But I'm mad now!"
Now Matthew and his colleagues
have called this combination
of no self-control and no self-insight
about one's self-control, naivete.
So this is like the
pathologically uncontrolled person
who has no clue,
and actual humans are slightly
more with it than that,
and they lie somewhere
between this pathetic creature
and a very smart version of this
that David Laibson has
suggested of sophistication.
The people I'm going to talk about today
are neither as dumb as Homer Simpson
or as smart as David Laibson,
but there's a big gap between those two.
The third way in which
humans differ from econs
is that humans are nicer.
So econs are unboundedly unscrupulous.
Any interaction between
a human and an econ
is an opportunity for strategy,
and they will take advantage of it
if they think it's in
their long-run interest.
Now, in Matthew's honor,
I'm bringing my empirical
evidence of this.
This is the fruit stand in Ithica.
It's selling rhubarb.
You can't quite see the rhubarb,
but you can see the sign,
and you can see the box with the lock.
This is really my model of human nature,
which is that there are enough
people who will put money in
that it's worthwhile for the
farmer to put the rhubarb out,
but there's also enough econs around
who will take the money if
you just leave it lying there.
So finally, we get to markets.
And behavioral economics
is a branch of economics,
a way of doing economics,
not a branch of psychology,
precisely because what we think about
is what happens when you
put humans into markets,
and especially if
there's some econs around
trying to take advantage of them.
Now, the standard assumption about markets
is that they are efficient.
And here's my proof that they're not.
(audience laughing)
Now, this is a picture that
was taken in Buenos Aires.
And now, there are some
of my finance colleagues,
like Mark Rubenstein,
who's sitting up in the front of the room,
who will probably say,
"No, this is not a violation
of the law of one price,"
which is the fundamental
driver of finance theory.
"No, this is price discrimination
against stupid Americans
"who don't know the Spanish for oranges."
Now, notice they have to be so stupid
that they don't see that the
two pictures are identical.
(audience laughing)
Which kind of violates the
unlimited rationality hypothesis.
So you have to give up one or the other.
(audience laughing)
Now, Matthew would
prefer that I would stop
my discussion of finance at this point,
but some think this isn't
completely convincing.
So let me spend five minutes
on something more convincing.
The most efficient place,
where we would expect
markets to work best,
is financial markets because
the transactions costs are low,
essentially zero in most cases,
and the stakes are very large.
So if anything is gonna
work like a textbook model,
it should be the New York Stock Exchange.
So I got interested in finance
precisely because of this,
and it's sort of the New
York, New York model.
If you can make it there,
you can make it anywhere.
My feeling was if we could
make some inroads in finance,
then it would sort of diffuse this idea
that we're only about toy
problems in laboratories.
I was helped with one
of my first students,
I think in fact my first student,
a Belgian named Werner DeBondt.
And he wanted to do finance,
so I said, "Okay, why not?"
So we wanted to test one
principle of financial economics,
which is that you can't predict
the future from the past.
So markets can't be efficient
if this is violated,
because otherwise you
could make tons of money.
Now, at one point, Michael Jensen,
a leading proponent of market
efficiency at this time,
he's now become a
born-again, something else,
Jensen said famously that the
efficient market hypothesis
is the best established
fact in social science.
Now, it helped he hadn't
read much social science
at that time, but anyway,
that was his claim.
So here's what Werner and I did.
I mean, this is lazy finances.
Especially since Werner did all
the programming. (chuckling)
We formed portfolios of
the 50 biggest losers
over a five-year period and
then the 50 biggest winners.
And then we tracked those
portfolios for the next 5 years,
how would they do?
Now, the efficient market hypothesis
says they should do the
same, because remember,
you can't predict the
future from the past.
So we should just see, they
should be indistinguishable.
So here's what we find.
This is averaging over many years of data.
We see that losers do very well.
They outperform the market by about 30%.
The winners do poorly.
They underperform by about 10%.
And after five years, the
difference is about 40%.
Now, there's some funny
things in this chart.
You'll notice that the losers
are doing all their winning in January.
We have no idea why that was.
It happened to be true.
There are other funny things
that happened in January.
That seems to have sort
of died out over time
after academics started writing about it.
It kind of shifted around,
but this loser effect or
more general versions of it
is still quite robust.
It's called the value effect.
Now there was an army--
I was at Cornell when this was written.
There was an army of University of Chicago
finance graduates students put to work
to find our programming error.
Because it was known this
cannot possibly be true.
So what mistake did we make?
Well, it turns out
DeBondt, bless his heart,
doesn't make programming errors.
He didn't trust CAM regression programs
so he would write them
himself to check to make sure
that the CAM programs were working.
So here are the complaints.
The first is that these losers
must somehow be riskier than the winners
because otherwise, why
are they outperforming?
Now the standard measure
of risk at this time
was something called beta.
I won't go into what that is.
It's co-variants with
the market essentially.
The losers actually had
lower betas than the winners
so that couldn't have been it.
But then people started getting creative
in how they measured beta
and if you measured beta afterwards.
Well, a big argument ensued.
All I can say is no one
has ever found a way
in which these losers are
actually riskier than the winners.
But in some metaphysical sense,
if you want to call them
riskier, you're welcome to.
Then they pointed out that
the losers were smaller,
and there's a well-known phenomena
that smaller stocks
outperform bigger stocks.
Now what's true is they
had become smaller.
They didn't start out that small,
but if you're the 50
worst-performing stocks
over a five year period,
you've really shrunk,
and in any case, finance
has absolutely no theory
about why portfolios of
small firms should do worse
than big firms.
So this is really just
shifting the anomaly
from one place to another.
So I'm gonna spare you
the thirty years of arguing about this
and move on to the other
dimension of market efficiency,
the price is right.
The idea here is that
in an efficient market
prices are equal to the
intrinsic value of the asset.
So that's the second pillar
of efficient market theory,
and in some ways, it's
an easier one to defend
than the first one
because most of the time,
it's not testable.
And that's handy if you
want to defend a theory
is to make it untestable,
and it's untestable because
you don't know intrinsic value.
Stocks don't come with labels saying,
"Here's my intrinsic value."
So you need to be clever to
figure out how to test this.
I have a colleague who's clever,
a guy called Owen Lamont, one
of my colleagues at Chicago,
and here's the story we investigated.
There was a company in
Silicon Valley in the 1990s,
and if you will remember
back to the 1990s,
the stock market was going up very fast,
tech companies were
doubling every few weeks,
and it was an exciting time
to be a stock on the NASDAQ.
But 3Com which owned Palm Pilots,
which you can think of as a
very clunky version of an iPhone
that doesn't make calls,
but it was thought to be
quite sexy at the time,
3Com is being ignored.
So here's a plot of 3Com's
stock price during this period.
Here's the summer of 1999
which was a very exciting time
for NASDAQ stocks but not for 3Com.
So 3Com decides, "We
need to unleash value,
"and how we're gonna do that,
we're gonna spin off Palm"
"and make it its own company."
Now of course, in an efficient market,
it would make no difference
whether Palm is inside of 3Com or outside.
However, you can see the
market really liked this idea.
So they announce here that
they're gonna spin off Palm,
and their stock price
jumps from about 42 to 100.
And as the IPO of Palm
gets nearer and nearer,
3Com is racing up.
So here are the details of the spin off.
The details are important.
This second bullet is the crucial number.
Each 3Com shareholder
gets 1.5 shares of Palm.
Now with my high-powered mathematics,
I'm able to derive the
following inequality
that that means that 3Com's share price
must be equal or greater
than 1.5 Palm because
every 3Com shareholder got
one and half shares of Palm.
Okay?
On the first day of trading,
the market goes crazy over Palm.
At one point the price is as high as $165,
and ends up settling
the day at $95 a share.
Now if you multiply $95
by 1.5, you get $142.
Remember, 3Com was selling for $100.
So that means it should go up by 42%.
Actually, it fell.
It fell by 20%.
And at the close of the market,
the market was valuing 3Com, the stub,
meaning its value less
its interest in Palm,
at minus $23 billion.
Now there's a really
basic principle of finance
which is asset prices cannot be negative.
(audience laughing)
Right?
Because you can throw them away.
But here we go, minus $23
billion, that's fairly negative.
Here's a plot.
So 3Com's stub was worth minus $60 a share
at the end of that day.
Some sanity came in the next day.
It was only worth minus $38 a share,
and then it lasted for several months.
Finally, at the IPO
when Palm was released,
3Com was worth some positive amount,
which of course it had to be.
It couldn't be worth a negative amount
once it started trading.
Okay, so where does this leave us?
We're more like homer
economicus than homo economicus,
and markets are not perfect.
So what does that mean for government?
Does that mean that we should
have governments come in
and run everything?
Should we abandon markets and
adopt Soviet-style systems?
Well, you can guess my
answer to that is no,
and in part because of the realization
that governments are run by humans too,
and in fact, running an economy
is an impossibly complicated task.
So what the role of government should be
is an interesting problem
with not an obvious answer,
and that of course is what Cass and I
try to address in our book.
I should say Cass is probably
the most distinguished
constitutional law professor
of his era, a great friend,
and now is, well in the media,
they call him "the regulation czar."
His official title is he's
the Director of the Office
of Information and Regulatory Affairs.
And so, I call him the nudger-in-chief.
So when we set out to write this book,
Cass likes to write books.
I had never really written a book.
I had stapled a couple,
collections of papers.
Have we mentioned my laziness?
Yeah, I think that's come up.
So when we wrote this
book, we had two goals.
We called them, when we were
talking among ourselves,
the ambitious goal and the
ridiculously ambitious goal.
So the ambitious goal was to take
the work I and my corrupted young friends
have been doing for 30 years or so
and bring it to a lay audience
and see what it might have
to say about public policy.
So that was the ambitious goal.
The ridiculously ambitious goal
was to try to create a political framework
that was neither left nor right.
And now, in the US, that
is a ridiculous goal,
and Glen Beck has decided
that Cass Sunstein is the
most dangerous man in America.
Quite an honor, I think, for Cass but--
(audience laughing)
Glen Beck doesn't know much about me.
If he knew, he would realize
I'm more dangerous inherently,
but Cass has a more dangerous job.
But in other countries there's some hope
that this approach that I'm
going to talk to you about
isn't really ideological.
So the conservative party in the UK has,
David Cameron read the book
and one summer, assigned
it to all the Tory MPs,
and they recently created
what is known in number 10
as the nudge unit.
The official name is the
behavioral insight team,
and I'm an advisor to that group.
And our charge is to think of ways
of using behavioral science to improve
whatever government is doing.
Now, it is fair to say that the
conservative party in the UK
is not very different from the
Democratic party in the US,
but I'm just back from Korea
where the prime minister there
is a conservative by any definition.
He also assigned the book to his cabinet,
and so there is some hope, we think,
that what I'm about to tell you about
could be an idea that
either party could take on.
So what is that idea?
It comes with a really snappy
name: libertarian paternalism.
Now as you know, both of those words
are unpopular in this country.
Libertarians are thought to be
crazy people who live in
Montana and Hyde Park,
a neighborhood in Chicago,
but they're loved compared to paternalists
who are reviled everywhere,
possibly even in Berkeley.
So our idea was to take these
two hated, contradictory words
and combine them.
Right, that's a winner.
Here's the way we do that.
By libertarian, what we mean
simply is choice preserving.
So we never want to tell
anybody what they have to do.
By paternalism, we simply mean
that we care about people's outcomes
as defined by themselves.
So that's what we want to do,
and how do we achieve this?
We achieve it with something
we call choice architecture.
So who is a choice architect?
A choice architect is anyone
who designs the environment
in which we choose.
Consider if you go to a restaurant,
the chef has decided what food
items he or she will prepare,
but there's someone who gets
to put that on a piece of paper
and in some order.
So the place we went to lunch today,
what's it called, Gather,
a very nice restaurant,
there were three categories of things.
There were salads, there were pizzas,
and there were sandwiches, and
maybe there was a fourth one.
Now it needn't be grouped
in that way, but they were.
And then within each
category, there's some order.
Somebody's deciding that.
Well that person is the choice architect.
Now, so what?
Well here's the most important
point I'm gonna make today.
There's no alternative
to choice architecture.
Sometimes people accuse
Cass and I of meddling.
The point I want you to leave with today
is it's impossible not to meddle.
So here's the example we
used to start the book.
Suppose that the director of
school cafeterias in Berkeley
discovers through experimentation
that the order in which
the food is displayed
influences what the kids eat.
So if the tofu is in front of the yogurt,
then more people will take
it than the other way around.
I assume those are the only
two things that are served.
(audience laughing)
At the Berkeley school cafeteria.
Now, armed with that
information, what should she do?
How should she arrange the food?
Well, one choice would be to
arrange the food in such a way
as to make the kids healthy and happy.
So somehow defined,
make the kids best off.
Okay, that's one option.
She could try to make the kids fatter.
She could fool herself into thinking
she can avoid choice architecture
by arranging the food at random,
but of course that's
just gonna create havoc.
Imagine if all the
ingredients in the salad bar
are scattered all around the room.
So the lettuce is over there,
and the tomato's over here
and the dressings are back there.
Right, the line will
come to a complete stop.
Or she could follow the Illinois,
state of Illinois model
and feature the items
for which it gets the largest bribes.
But again, the point I want to make is
she must choose something.
It's impossible not to meddle.
So given that, we argue,
why not pick something good?
Now, this was a hypothetical example.
Right, this came out of my
head this school cafeteria.
There's no study that I knew of.
It just made sense to me
that that would be true.
Thanks to Brian Wansink,
the author of a brilliant
book called "Mindless Eating"
this hypothetical example is now true.
So he's doing experiments
in school cafeterias.
He's actually rearranging the food.
So in one school, they've
increased the salad uptake
just by moving the salad bar.
In another school, they've
increased the fruit consumption
by putting the fruit in a nicer display.
And if you're interested in this,
look at Brian Wansink's website
or go to smarterlunchrooms.org.
They just got a million dollar
grant from the government
to continue this work.
Now so that's one sort of high-brow nudge.
Here's a more famous one.
This is a picture of the urinal
in Schiphol Airport in Amsterdam.
You can see if you just squint,
there's something in there.
So I have a blow up of
that. (audience laughing)
So some genius (audience laughing)
decided that if you etch
the image of a housefly
in the urinals then-- (audience laughing)
Now, I have to explain this that men,
we have a lot on our minds, you know?
(audience laughing)
"The Giants have a big game tonight,"
who are we going to start
in our fantasy football league team?
So while we're taking
care of our business,
we're thinking about other things.
And I'm sure there's an
evolutionary explanation
for what I'm about to say.
If you give us a target, we will aim.
(audience laughing)
So, and here's hard data.
Spillage has been reduced by--
I don't know the
empirical methods on this.
(audience laughing)
But we're just gonna take that as a given.
Now this is like a paragraph in our book,
but it's probably had
thousands of newspaper articles
written about it.
We have a chapter on choice architecture
that I don't have time to go into.
And we detail six principles
of good choice architecture.
Today I'm gonna just talk about defaults.
Here's one example that
we're working on in the UK.
In the US in most states, if
you want to donate your organs,
should you have a sudden accident,
you have to take some action.
You have to fill out some
form or do something.
So it's an opt-in system.
In some countries in
Europe, most notably Spain,
they have an opt-out system
that they call presumed consent.
And the way that works is you
are presumed to give your
consent unless you do something.
Now the Labor government
in the UK wanted to switch
from the opt-in system
to presumed consent,
but there was a big fuss made.
Some people objected to someone else
presuming something
about their body parts.
And so, what I'm urging
their government to do
and I think what they may do
is adopt what I call prompted choice.
Now in the book we refer
to this as mandated choice.
I've learned a lot about
politics in the last two years.
Prompted choice is exactly the
same policy but sounds better
so we call it prompted choice.
This is actually something the
state of Illinois does right.
When you go to get your
driver's license renewed,
the last question the clerk
at the DMV asks you is,
"Would you like to be an
organ donor, yes or no?"
Now, I called it mandated choice.
Somebody wrote a newspaper
article about this,
and the secretary of
state in Illinois said,
"No, we don't have that."
So I got a call from the reporter,
"The state claims they don't have it."
I don't know what he's talking about.
I've been there, I know.
It turns out he just
didn't like "mandated."
He says, "We don't enforce
anybody to do anything."
So technically he's right.
If you get up to the front
of the line, and they say,
"Do you want to be a donor or not?"
and you stand there
mum, (audience laughing)
they will check "No" and give
you your driver's license.
So that's why we now
call it prompted choice.
And that's the model I think
will probably adopt in the UK.
I wrote an article about
this in the New York Times
where I have an occasional column,
and I said that Steve Jobs,
who had just recently
gotten a liver transplant,
should take it upon himself
to make it as easy to donate your organs
as it is to download an app on an iPhone.
Two weeks later, there was an app.
Steve Jobs had nothing to do with it.
Somebody read the article,
thought it was a good idea.
If you have an iPhone, you
can download Donate Lives
and sign up to be an organ donor
and maybe we can save a few lives today.
Now, another domain in
which default options has
proven to be very powerful
is in 401(k) plans.
Many 401(k) plans,
participants never get
around to signing up.
They procrastinate.
So in a normal plan, if
you want to join the plan,
you've got a big pile
of forms to fill out,
you have to fill those out.
If you don't, you're not in.
Under the alternative, which
is called automatic enrollment,
you get that big pile of
forms and the first page says,
"If you don't fill out these forms,
"we're gonna enroll
you at this saving rate
"and in this investment plan."
Well that jumps enrollment
immediately to over 90%
in every firm that's tried it.
And importantly, very few
people wake up a few years later
and say, "Oh my God, I'm saving!
"What a stupid idea," and drop out.
(audience laughing)
Now the downside of
automatic enrollment is
that whatever you make as the default,
many people will take.
And so many companies make the
default saving rate quite low
and the deferred investment
very conservative,
so we advise now firms to have
a more sensible default plan
like something that re-balances
the portfolio automatically
and adjusts it over time.
And Shlomo Benartzi, another
one of my students, and I
have created a program that
we call Save More Tomorrow
to solve the saving rate problem,
and what we do is we invite
participants to sign up
for a program where they save more later.
And the reason for that is
that we all have more self-control
in the future than now.
So many of us are planning
diets starting next month,
including me.
So we give them the option of
saving more in a few months,
when they get their next raise
because we want to mitigate
against loss aversion.
So they never see their pay go down.
In the first company that adopted this,
we tripled saving rates
in less than three years.
That was a special case
where we went around
to each employee with a laptop
and sort of led them by the hand.
Sign up rates have never been that high
in other less costly implementations.
But everywhere, it's now available
in thousands of companies
serving millions of employees,
and wherever it works, the
people who get into it stick,
and their savings rates go up.
Now, I'm gonna switch to
an idea that's less sexy
but I think is getting some traction
in Washington and elsewhere.
It's a very geeky idea.
And the idea is a simple one.
Wherever the government has
a required disclosure rule,
they would supplement that
with an electronic disclosure.
And the disclosure where applicable
would have two kinds of information,
one about prices and one about uses.
So let me explain how this might work
for wireless calling plans
which is very relevant
because the FCC is
seriously thinking about
adopting some version of this idea.
So the idea would be once a year,
you would get an email from
your mobile calling plan
that would have essentially
a spreadsheet attached to it,
and it would have data on every way
in which you used your phone
that incurred a charge.
So how many text messages,
how many mega-whatevers
of things you've downloaded,
and how many Simpsons
episodes you've downloaded.
And then, the second would be a list of
all the ways they can
charge you for things.
Now it's not that we think anyone
would ever look at that file.
What we think is, what we know is,
because these websites already exist,
is that with one click, you
would be able to upload that
to a website that would
then turn you into an econ.
And it would tell you,
"Well, based on the way
you use your smartphone,
"we suggest that you switch
to the following plan,"
or the following provider or so forth.
We think we should do
this with credit cards,
with mortgages.
You know those 30 pages of
forms you have to fill out
when you get a mortgage
that no one ever reads?
Including, we now know,
the people foreclosing on those mortgages?
Again, we think that
you ought to get a file
when you apply for a mortgage
that you could upload
to mortgagesearcher.com
and it would tell you,
"Well, do you notice
that this mortgage rate
"doubles in two years?"
Or, "There's a $25,000
pre-payment penalty."
Or all the other stuff in the fine print
that nobody every bothers to read.
What we think is that in many cases,
this kind of disclosure
can be an alternative
to heavy-handed regulation.
And the reason is you
just are trying to make
the consumer smarter and
the markets work better.
And it eliminates the fruitless game
of constantly thinking up new regulations
that the firms are thinking
up ways to getting around.
And so I would urge Elizabeth Warren
to think very hard about this approach
to dealing with the new consumer
finance protection agency.
It also should allow for innovation,
because if you want to
introduce a new product,
you just need a new line
on this electronic form
which is easy to accommodate.
Now, the last thing I want to talk about
is the financial crisis and
some interesting parallels
I've drawn between the financial crisis
and the oil spill we had
in the Gulf of Mexico.
And I want to suggest
that three ingredients
create a toxic recipe.
The three ingredients are
statistically rare events,
in Taleb's language, "black swans,"
complex technologies that
I'll call "black boxes,"
and counterparty risk
meaning you have to do
business with somebody else
and you're not quite
sure what they're doing.
So about black swans,
in financial markets we
keep observing things
that the theory tells us can't happen.
So behavioral finance got a
big boost on October 19th, 1987
when stock prices fell
20 to 30% in a single day
all around the world on a
day with absolutely no news.
The only news was that stock prices
were falling all around the world,
one country after another
as the stock markets opened.
It wasn't that ten heads of
state died in a bomb at the UN
or that a war was breaking
out in the Middle East.
Nothing happened.
The rest of that week had
two of the biggest up days
and another of the biggest down days.
Again, in a week, the only news was
that the market was going crazy.
We've had more of those
happening every few years.
The internet bubble, where
we created and destroyed
seven trillion dollars of wealth,
and most recently, the financial crisis.
People will tell you
these are 10 sigma events
or 15 sigma events.
We know we can't get those.
Maybe once every hundred
million lifetimes.
So what's going on, at some point,
when a lot of these events keep happening,
you have to decide you
have the wrong model.
Now there's a wonderful book
I wish you could all read.
I just recently gave a
lecture about this at Yale.
The author of this book
was a law professor
called Arthur Leff.
The book's called "Swindling and Selling."
It's been out of print for 30 years,
although you can find it on Amazon.
He talks about all the great
cons and about Ponzi schemes,
and he introduces the
notion of the gray box.
And so the theme of the
book is for every con
the conman has to explain
the answers to two questions:
where is the wealth coming from,
and why are you willing
to share it with me?
And as this passage
says, in a Ponzi scheme,
the original Ponzi had
an arbitrage opportunity.
He claimed he had figured out a way
of investing depreciated
European currencies
in international postage
coupons and making a killing.
So all Ponzi-ers since
have some mechanism that they
describe, and as Leff says,
the mechanism need not be
very plausible upon reflection
but it most be possible,
publicizable, and complicated.
It cannot be a black box,
but it cannot be transparent.
It needs to be a gray box,
somewhat understandable but not so much
that it can be seen through.
Now why is that?
Gray box must be
believable and unbelievable
at the same time.
It has to be understandable
that some people won't want it.
That's why you're getting the deal.
Now, think about Wall Street.
First, the financial crisis.
The most perceptive article
in all that's been written
about the Financial Crisis
was written by a New Yorker food writer
called Calvin Trillin,
and Trillin describes an
imaginary scene at an Eastside bar
where he goes into the bar
and meets an elderly
gentleman, well-dressed,
who offers to explain the
Financial Crisis to him.
He says he can do it in one sentence.
"Okay, what's that?"
He says, "Smart people started
working on Wall Street."
Says, "Okay, well I'm
not sure I get that."
So he says, "Well, back
when I was in school
"only the C students went to Wall Street.
"The A and B students
wouldn't touch Wall Street.
"They went into good careers
like law or medicine.
"But then in the '80s,
"people started making a
lot of money on Wall Street,
"and all of a sudden, the
brightest, smartest kids
"from all the best colleges
flocked to Wall Street
"where they were making millions."
So Mr. Trillin says,
"Okay, so far, so good.
"I don't see what the problem is."
He says, "Yes, but who are all
those smart kids working for?
"The guys from my
generation, the C students."
Now, I think that story
is so perceptive because
we've seen after the fact that many CEOs
just didn't understand what was going on.
Even Bob Rubin, the most respected,
one of the most respected
men on Wall Street,
former secretary of the treasury,
admitted that he had never
heard the phrase "liquidity put"
until Citicorp had lost $50
billion selling liquidity puts.
And Bernie Madoff, who sold $65
billion worth of gray boxes,
how did he sell them?
He had some story, a story
that any finance professor
with after five minutes would say,
"This is not possible for you
to make money doing this."
Why did people put their money in?
They thought he was frontrunning.
Now frontrunning means,
he had a trading company,
a legitimate, presumably
legitimate trading company.
What frontrunning means is
suppose Matthew calls his broker
and decides to buy 100,000 shares of IBM,
and the broker quickly
buys a 100,000 shares for himself first.
That drives up the price,
he sells those to Matthew.
So that's a pretty sure way
of making a little money
each time you trade.
It's illegal, but--
That's what many of the
investors in the feeder funds
thought Madoff was doing.
And they thought, "This is fine,
"because he's stealing from someone else
"and giving the money to me."
(audience laughing)
Which constitutes ethics these
days. (audience laughing)
Here's some facts about the SEC.
They have 1400 lawyers, 25 economists,
and I don't know how many hackers.
I am pretty sure that if
they could clone Salander
and put her in the SEC,
that could replace several hundred lawyers
and probably most of the economists,
but the SEC was a job
that used to be suitable
for an agency of lawyers,
but the SEC investigated
Madoff many times,
couldn't find anything wrong with it.
Finally, counterparty risk,
I'll just quote Mr. Greenspan.
In fact, I'll let you read that
while I get a sip of water.
Okay, now the oil spill.
Tony Hayward said this oil spill
was a one-in-a-million chance.
Now whenever somebody says that,
you have a pretty good idea,
that was not a precise calculation.
(audience laughing)
But if you look at the numbers,
there are 15,000 wells
in the Gulf of Mexico.
In 11 cases, there was an accident
in which they had to use
the blowout preventer.
The blowout preventer
worked 45% of the time.
That was their fail safe mechanism,
works less than half the time.
And if what he meant by one-in-a-million
was one-in-a-million per year per well,
you can see over a period of time,
we're gonna get some spills.
Again, the regulators
are not used to dealing
with oil wells that are a mile down.
So one of the inspectors said,
you know, we don't really have
the capability of doing this.
And counterparty risks, on
the day of the accident,
of the 126 people on the rig,
only eight worked for BP.
So what are we gonna do about this?
Well one trap is to conclude
that we should give lots
of power to regulators.
But remember, regulators are human too,
and it's unlikely that if
the CEOs didn't understand
what was going on in a company
that some bureaucrat will be able to
no matter how good the bureaucrat is.
So one goal, I think, should
be to increase transparency
which will allow more
people to get involved.
So the rating agencies let us down.
I think with more disclosure,
we wouldn't have needed
the rating agencies.
If every mortgage-backed security
had all the data on every
mortgage, which was known to them
and was possible to get
if you paid enough money,
if that was all available
just like in our electronic disclosure,
then any geek could have
become a rating agency.
And in some cases, disclosure
will regulate risks
to the own firm.
Another possibility is to impose taxes
on those who impose risk.
So this is a topic of much
discussion, bank regulation.
It could also be for oil drillers.
The problem with this is A,
knowing how to measure the risk.
Is it one-in-a-million?
What is it?
Bankers would have told
us there was no chance
of this sort of break down.
Another approach could be to
require them to have insurance
which shifts some of the risk
from the government to the insurer,
but of course we can't be sure
whether the insurance companies
are fully up to the job.
So let me conclude.
Our world is getting increasingly complex,
but we're not getting any smarter.
Neither the private sector
nor the public sector
seems to up to the job of
dealing with this complexity.
To paraphrase something Larry Summers said
about financial regulation,
we need regulations that
don't require anybody
to get any smarter.
And by that, what he meant was
neither the consumers nor the regulators.
Because we can't hope that
the next round of regulators
will be smarter than the last round.
They're gonna be humans, too.
So I'll offer two rules.
Start with electronic disclosure,
and don't ban and mandate.
Just nudge.
Thank you very much.
(applauding)
(electronic synthesizer music)